From here.
Perspective.
Can you summarize the important events around this amazing saga that have been
living through of wall street bets, the subreddit and GameStop,
and in general,
just what are your thoughts about it from technical to the philosophical level?
I think it's amazing. It's like my favorite story ever.
Like when I was reading about it, I was like, this is the best. Um, and it's,
it's also, you know, connected with my company, which we can talk about,
but what I liked about it is like,
I like decentralized coordination and looking at the mechanisms that
these are wall street,
bets users use to hype each other up to get excited to
prove that they bought the stock and they're holding. Um, and,
and then also to see that how big of an impact that,
that decentralized coordination had, um, it really was a big deal.
Are you impressed by the distributed, uh, coordination,
the collaboration amongst, like, I dunno what the numbers are.
I know numerous looking at the data after all of this is over and
done. It'd be interesting to see, like from, uh,
a large scale distributed system perspective to see how everything played out.
But just from your current perspective, what we know,
is it obvious to you that such incredible level of coordination
could happen where a lot of people come together and distribute a sense there's
an emergent behavior that happens after that?
No, it's not at all obvious.
And one of the reasons is the lack of kind of like credibility to
coordinate with someone you need to kind of make credible contracts or credible
claims. So if you have, um, a username on, uh,
our wall street bets, like some of them are like deep value is why.
That's an actual username. By the way, we're talking about,
there's a website called Reddit and there's subreddits on it.
And a lot of people mostly anonymous,
I think for the most part anonymous, uh,
can create user accounts and then can then just talk on forum,
like style boards. You should know what Reddit is.
If you don't know what Reddit is, check it out. Uh,
if you don't know what red is, maybe go to, uh, the, uh,
awesome subreddit first. Aww, with cute pictures of cats and dogs.
That's my recommendation. Anyway.
That'd be a good start to read it. When you,
when you get into it more go to our wall three vets.
It gets dark quickly. Oh, we'll probably talk about that too. Uh, so,
so yeah, so there's these users and it's,
there's no contracts like you were saying.
Contracts, the, the, the user anonymous. Um, but there are little things that,
that do help. So for example,
if you've posted a really good investment idea in the past,
that exists on Reddit as well, and it might have lots of upvotes. Um,
and that's also kind of like giving credibility to your next to your next thing.
Um, and then they are also putting up screenshots like this. This is the,
these I, I, the trades I've made and here's a screenshot.
Now you could fake the screenshot, but, um, but, but still,
it seems like if you've got a lot of karma and you've had a good performance on
the, on the community,
it somehow becomes credible enough for other people to be like, you know what?
He actually probably did put a million dollars into this and you know what?
I can, I can follow that trade.
And there's a bunch of people like that. So you kind of, uh,
integrating all that information together yourself to see like, huh,
there's something happening here.
And then you jump onto this little boat of like behavior.
Like we should buy the stock or sell the stock.
And then another person jumps on another person jumps on. And, uh,
all of a sudden you have just a huge number of people behaving in the same
direction. It's like flock of whatever birds, right.
Exactly. What was strange with this one. It wasn't just, let's all buy Tesla.
We love Elon. We love the Tesla. Let's,
let's all buy Tesla because that we've heard before. Right. Everybody likes,
um, Tesla. Well, now they do. Um,
so what they did with this, in this case, they're buying a stock that was bad.
They're buying it because it was bad.
And that's really weird because that's a little bit, um,
to galaxy brain for, for us decentralized community. Um,
how did they come up with it? How do they know that was the right one?
And the reason they liked it is because it had really, really high,
short interest. It had been shorted, uh, more than its own, uh, flow,
I believe. Um,
and so they figured out that if they all bought this bad stock,
they could short squeeze some hedge funds and those hedge funds would
have to put you late and buy the stock at really, really high prices.
And we should say that shorted means that it's either a bunch of people.
When you short a stock, you're betting on the F on the you're predicting,
the stock is going to go down and then you will make money if it does. And then,
uh, what's a short squeeze.
It's really that if you,
if you are a hedge fund and you take a big short position in a, in a company,
um, there's a certain level at which you can't sustain holding that
position, right. Uh, there's no limit to how high a stock can go,
but there is a limit to how low it can go, right? So if you short something,
you have infinite loss potential.
And if the stock doubles overnight like GameStop did, um,
you're putting a lot of stress on that hedge fund.
And that hedge fund manager might have to say,
you know what I have to get out of the trade.
And the only way to get out is to buy the bad stock that they don't want.
Like they believe will go down. Uh, so it's an interesting situation,
particularly because it's not zero sum. If you say,
let's meet, let's all get together and make a bubble in watermelons,
you buy a bunch of watermelons. That price goes up, it comes down again.
It's this, it's a, it's a zero sum game.
If someone's already shorted stock and you can make them short squeeze,
it's actually a positive sum game. So yes,
some Redditors will make a lot of money. Some will lose a lot,
but actually the whole group will make money. And that's really, uh,
that's really why it's such a clever thing for them to do.
Uh, coupled with the fact that shorting, I mean, maybe you can push back,
but to me, always from an outsider's perspective seemed,
I hope I'm not using too strong of a word, but it seemed almost unethical.
Maybe not unethical. Maybe it's just the thing to do. It's okay.
I'm speaking, not from an economics or financial perspective,
I'm speaking from just somebody who loves. I'm a fan of a lot of people.
I love celebrating the success of a lot of people.
And this is like the stock market equivalent of like
haters. I know that's not what it is. I know that there's efficient.
You want to have in the economy, efficient mechanism for punishing, uh,
sort of over-hyped overvalued things.
That's what short Angus is designed for,
but it just always felt like these people are just because they're not just
betting on the loss of the company.
It feels like they're also using their leverage and power to manipulate
media, or just to write articles or just to hate on you on social media.
And then you get to see that with the all mosque and so on. So,
so this is like the man,
the sh people like hedge funds that were shorting are like the,
the sort of embodiment of the evil,
or just the bad guy, the over powerful, this misusing their power.
And here's the crowd. The people are standing up and rising up.
So it's not just that they were able to collaborate on wall street
bets to sort of effectively make money for themselves. It's also,
this is like a symbol of the people getting together and
fighting the centralized elites, the powerful, and that, you know,
I don't know what your thoughts are about that in general, at this stage,
it feels like that's really exciting that people have
power just like regular people have power at the same time.
It's scary a little bit, because, you know,
just studying history, people could be manipulated by charismatic leaders.
And so like, uh, just like Ilan right now is like manipulating, uh,
encouraging people to buy doors coin or whatever. Uh, the, the,
like there can be good charismatic leaders and there could be bad charismatic
leaders. And so it's nerve wracking. It's,
it's a little bit scary how much power subreddit can have to, uh,
destroy somebody,
because right now we're celebrating there might be attacking or destroying
somebody that everybody doesn't like,
but what if they attack somebody that is actually good for this world? So that,
and that's kind of the,
the awesomeness and the price of freedom
is like, it could destroy the world or can save the world.
But at this stage it feels like, I don't know. Overall, when you sit back,
do you think this was just a positive wave of emergent behavior?
Is it because there's something negative about what?
Well, yeah, the, the cool thing is the, they weren't doing anything. The,
the red people weren't doing anything, um, exotic. It was,
it was a creative trade, but it wasn't exotic. It wasn't,
it was just buying the stock. Okay. Maybe they bought some options too, but,
um, it was the hedge fund that was doing the exotic thing. Um,
so I liked that. It was, it's hard to say, well, you know,
we've got together and we put all pooled all our money together,
and now there's a company out there that's worth more. What's wrong with that.
Yeah. Right. But it doesn't talk about, you know, the motivations, which is,
and then we destroyed some hedge funds in the process.
He said about the, the humor. And, um,
I don't know the edginess, sometimes viciousness of that subreddit.
I haven't looked at it too much,
but it feels like people can be quite aggressive on their, uh,
so is there, what is that, is that,
what is that, what a freedom looks like?
I think it does. Yeah. You definitely need to let people, the,
one of the things that people have compared it to is the occupy wall street.
Right. Which is, let's say, you know, some very sincere, uh, liberals,
like 23 years old, whatever. And they go out with signs and they,
they have some kind of case to make. Um, but this isn't sincere, uh,
really, um, it's like, um, a little bit more nihilistic,
a little bit more Yolo. Um,
and therefore a little bit more scary because he's scared of the,
who's scared of the wall street, occupy wall street, people with the signs.
Right. Nobody, but these hedge funds really are scared. I was scared of the, uh,
of the wall street, bets people. I'm still scared of them. Yeah.
The anonymity is a bit terrifying and exciting.
Yeah. I mean, yeah. I.
I don't know what to do with it. You know, I've been following events in Russia,
for example, it's like,
there's a struggle between centralized power and the distributed. I mean,
that's the struggle of, uh, the history of human civilization. Right. But this,
on the internet, just that you can multiply, uh,
people, like some of them don't have to be real.
Like you can probably create bots. Like it starts getting me,
me as a programmer. I started to think like, Hmm, me is one person.
How much cash can, can I create by writing some bots? Yeah.
And I'm sure I'm not the only one thinking that, uh, there's,
I'm sure there's the hundreds, thousands of, uh,
good developers out there listening to this thinking the same thing.
And then as that develops further and further in the next decade or two,
what impact does that have on financial markets on just destruction
of, uh, reputations of just,
or politics, you know, the, the bickering of left and right.
Political discourse, the dynamics of that be manipulated by, you know,
people talk about like Russian bots or whatever. I,
we're probably in the very early stage of that. Right. Exactly. And, uh,
this is a good example. So do you have,
do you have a sense that most of wall street bets folks are actually individual
people, right. That that's the feeling I have is there's just individual,
maybe young investors just doing a little bit of an investment,
but just on a larger scale.
Yeah, exactly. The reason I found out, well,
I've known about all three reds for a while,
but the reason I found about GameStop was this just,
I met somebody at a party who told me about it and he was like 21 years old.
And he's like, it's going to go up a hundred percent. And the next one day.
We're talking about in last year.
Uh, this was probably, no, this was yeah. A few days ago when I, yeah.
It was like maybe, um, maybe two weeks ago or something. Um,
so it was, it was already high game stuff. Um,
but it was just strange to me that there was someone telling me at a party, uh,
how to trade stocks, who was like 21 years old. Um, and, uh,
and it started, yeah. I started to look into it and, um, yeah, he did make,
he made it, I made 140% in one day. Uh, he was right. And now he's,
um, you know, supercharged, he's a little bit wealthier and now he's gonna look,
wait for the next thing.
And this decentralized entity is just going to get bigger. Yeah.
And they're gonna together search for the next thing.
So there's thousands of folks like him,
and they're going to probably search for the next thing to attack people that
have power in this world that sit there with power right now in government and
in finance,
in any kind of position are probably a little bit scared right now.
And honestly, that's probably a little bit good. It's dangerous, but it's good.
Yeah. It certainly makes you think twice about shorting.
And certainly it makes you think twice about putting a lot of money into a
short, like these funds put a lot into one, one or two names.
And so it was very, very badly risked managed.